サッバパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
現代流行っている言葉を二つテーマにしてありますが
まあこんなことを喋りたくない
私は ネット社会で流行っている単語ですけどね
この単語の中に入っている仏教の心理学について説明します
なぜならば 私も一回どこかの講演で例に出しましたけど MeToo
という運動が始まって
アメリカでね 女性差別されているところは
もう偉い人々がね すごいセクハラやっていて
何とも言えないんですね
あまりも権力を持ってるんだからね
それで困っていた女性たちや女優さんたちとかね
大物の方々なんですよ
だからまあ そういう誰々さんがね
それに反対したことをね MeTooMeToo
でハラスメントですからね
書いて そこで力になって
かなりそういうなかなか
触ることすらできない
こういうセクハラやっている人々が
もう結局は裁判に当たりはめになったんですね
ただのネットでね まあ賛成するだけの言葉ですごい力になっちゃったんですね
だから私たちは この現代社会では
このFACEBOOKやらね FACEBOOK
には最近いろいろトラブルがあるんですが
で ツイッターとかね まあそういうところで情報発信して
何かすごい社会的にいろんな変化が起こっちゃうんですね
だから この力って何なのかと今日勉強してみましょう
ただ LIKEボタンを押しただけなんですけどね
あるいはディスLIKEボタンを押しただけなんですけど
まあでもなんかすごい力が働いてるんですね
その裏に 私はちなみにやりません LIKE
もディスLIKEも押しません
押しません で たまにたまに稀に発言するところはあるんだけど
それも 1行 2行に終了するんです
あれってかなり稀なケースなんですね
他は全然  それはいたって簡単
なんでバカの仲間にならなくちゃあかんかっていうね YES
と言ったって NOと言ったってバカの仲間だからね
これは神の力か悪魔の力かと
なんかよくわからないんですね
だってテロリストさえネット使っていて
情報発信して仲間作ってるんだから
だからISISには至って簡単にメンバーが入りますよ
ネットなんですね それでまあ政府すら倒すことはできますよ
すごい力なんですね だから問題は
これは神の力か悪魔の力かって
皆様大体西洋文化的だからね
そういう単語を使ってますけどね
日本文化ではないんだから
人間はそういう風に神か悪魔かと思わないんですけどね
だからまあ心理語ってるのは仏教だから
仏教の教えから ブッダの教えから
これはどんな力なのかっていうことは
これからまあ理解していきましょう
で ブッダの幸福学なんですね
ブッダはただ説明して
はい さようならではないんですね
だったら人間にやるべきことも教えてあげるんですよ
で まず心の立場 これは悪魔でもない
神でもないんですよ 結局は心なんですね
心といえば 誰にだって心があるんですね
すべての生命に心があるんですね
生命とは心の機能があるという定義になるんですね
人は物質至上主義で主義の立場をとっています
しかし 我々人間たちはいつでも物質至上主義だと思っているんですね
心について語ると 面白くない
役に立たない 宗教だ あるいは非科学的だ
あるいは釈迦ちゃんということで
あの 王道にしないんですね
心は まあまあ そのうちということで
何よりも金だという感じで生きているんですね
親孝行するより先は金だと
時々何人もいたんだからね
親がちょっと病気で倒れたんだけど
私はこのお見舞いに行くべきか
行って行かなくてもいいんでしょうかと私に聞くんですね
そう なんでやと言ったら
会社に仕事あるんだと
だからそういう失踪する連中はね
まず人間失格 だから親死んだっても金が先ということなんですね
だから心はもうより金が
金っていうのは総合的な単語で
物質が 正しいと 仏教は心とは一切物事の指導者優先と解くのです
仏教は全く違うことを言うんです
心がすべての物事の指導者
指令する者 物事を管理する者
で 何よりも心が優先であると
これはもうどうすることもできないんです
これは絶対的立場なんです
心が優先と ということは
人間が何よりも金だと言っているんだけど
心がなければ金儲からないということを忘れているんです
だから金儲かるか損するか
自分の心次第でしょうに
だから心が金持ちになると決めたら金持ちになります
心がしっかりとどん底貧乏になろうと思ったらできます
ですから この心が優先であること
その立場は不動で変わらないんですよ
そこで物質には何もできない
物質に物理学で発見している変化以外何もできない
物質は変化する 太陽はね
まあずっと燃えて変化する
それ以外のことを太陽にできますか？できません
地球は自転しているし
もうそれ以上何にもできません
そこで物質の変化っていうのは
もうほとんど今は科学者が知り尽くしているところに来ているんです
量子力学もね 力学も今進んでいるし
だから物はあるかないかというところまで物理世界はもう進んでいるんですよ
私は昔読んだ文章で 物理学ではまああまりやることは残っていないんだと
これ以上は そこまで書いた人がいるんでしょう
ということは くだらない人間にも理解することできるものだから
物質は大したことないんです
物質というのはただ決まっているパターンで
物理学で我々発見している
あのパターンで変化している
物質の先は読める 予測できる
これから物質どうなるのかということは
皆様が預言者でなくても予言できますね
だから物質至上主義だから
皆様 我は預言者であると自称しても構いませんよ
だって物質至上主義で生きているんだから
まあ例えばね 後から 40年経ったらね
ここら辺でいる方々は何人いるのかどうかね
私はいないんだけどね
わかるでしょうに だから相当な預言者なんですね
だから物質の先っていうのは
まあ子供に聞いてもね
何かみかんでもあげて
このみかんは何日持ちますかというと
子供もそれなりに言うでしょう
まあせいぜい 1週間ぐらいとかね
心に物質の変化を自分の希望で変えることができます
しかし 変化をストップすることはできません
そこで何もできない 自分で勝手に変化する力以外
何も力を持っていない物質を心に変えることができるのです
しかし 変化のストップはできません
そこで簡単な例でね 皆様は肉を食べているでしょうね
肉っていうのは まあ 1 日経つと腐っちゃいますよ
死んだからはね しかし
私たちが食べている肉はだいたい 1年 2
年ぐらい経っているんです
冷凍保存しているんだから
私は時々冗談で言うんですけど
チキン料理して食べると
もしかするとこの鶏さんがどこかで生まれ変わって
またチキンになっちゃって
もうもうとっくに食べているかもしれません
食べられているかもしれませんと
で それぐらい 1 日で腐るものを
我々は 1 年も持つようにしている
あれってどんな力？人間アホだから人間思うのは
これ冷凍保存すれば これは冷凍庫
冷え 何こう ディープフリーザーのおかげだと
おかしいでしょうに 富士山散歩をすると
木の上でディープフリーザーが現れてくるのを見たことがある？ないでしょう
人間が作らなくちゃいけないんです
人間が温度のことを勉強して
温度をどうすれば下げることできるのか
人間がそれを勉強して
あの金具を作っちゃったんです
それに電気は世界にあるんだけど
どうすることもできないでしょうに
アクセスできない しかし
人間がこのおっかないかなわない電気を作って自由に使えるようにしていて
それで電気流して あの 1 日で腐る鶏の肉を 1 年も持つようにしているんです
だから明らかにそれは心のからくりでしょ
心が物質をいじったでしょ
だから物質に定めた運命が変わったでしょ
だから これ鋼鉄を包丁に変えることが心にできます
どこかに鋼鉄を置いておいて
まあ 1年待てば包丁になっている 1
年ではなくて  100年待ったっても
それはそのまま変化していて壊れているだけで包丁になりませんよ
そこに人の心が入ってくると包丁になるんです
じゃあ犬にも心がある
じゃあ犬の前に鋼鉄を置いておけば 2
日 3日で包丁になる？ならない
その心にその力がないんです
だから至って単純なこと
世の中を見ると だから地球がものすごい変でしょ？何一つの自然のものないでしょ？これって誰がやったんですか？人間の心がやったんです
この建物 自然のものではないんです
自然の摂理を我々は壊しちゃったんです
どこへ行ってももう自然はないんです
だから この地球全体的に変えることすら心にできちゃって
しかし 心は大事だと思わないんですね
これ読みません 棒 空棒で空棒が水に浮くことをも
飛行機が空を飛ぶことをも心はやってるわけです
だから人間 飛行機って不思議ですねとかね
エンジニアになりたいなとかね
これ心がやってるということは理解しないんです
一度も間違ってでも 人間の心というのは不思議ですねと思わないんですね
飛行機が不思議ですと
何の不思議もないんです
分解すればすぐわかります
なんでレーダーがある
レーダーって後ろの尾翼なんとかってあるのかとかね
なんでこう翼がこんな形なのかとかね
すぐわかりますよ 不思議なこと何もないんです
そちらに不思議なことは
それを考えて このからくりをわかって
こういうものを作った心なんですね
じゃあ人間の手で作ったって足で作ったとかね
心がなければ手足動かないでしょうに
だから心がちゃんとリーダーで指導者で管理者でやってるんです
この生命を それで私たちの問題は
心の自力とか言ったんで
わざと間違った単語を書きましたけど
心が自分で持っている力
自分の力に気づかないんですね
僕 先天的に問題があるんです
心に 心は物質に隠れるようにして働きます
この臆病な心が だからリーダーなのに臆病
なんだこれ なんか天皇陛下が人の前に出たくない
ちょっと緊張しちゃう
ちょっと震えるというような話でしょ
おかしいでしょ 逆でしょうに
一般人が天皇陛下の前で言葉も出なくなっちゃって
緊張して固まっちゃうんだから
天皇陛下はそういうことは言わない
もし言ったならば変でしょ
これ我々やっているんです
我々はいつでも物質が偉い偉いと
私はちょっと控えめで隠れていますという働きやっていますね
自分で物質をいじっているのに
物質の力に感動します
あまりにもアホなんですね
自分で飛行機作って 自分で空母を作って感動するんですよ
すごいこっちゃ これは
とかね  すごいよっこないものやとか
なんというアホかということになるんですね
肉体物質の場合も同じです
そこで我々は一番 皆様はそういう空法束ってないんだから
まあそれは関係ない話で
皆様は体のことをすごく優先に考えているでしょう
肉体のこと どうすれば痩せるのか
どうすれば老いることをやめさせるのかとかね
どうすれば年取っても年取ってもピチピチ若く見えるのかとかね
どうすれば髪の毛が落ちないのかとかね
男性の場合は そういうことばっかり考えているんです
だからかっこ悪いんですよ
この腐る肉体のために肉体を拝んで肉体を信仰して生きているんです
あまりにも気持ち悪いんですよ
それもう遺体を拝んでるような感じなんで
まあ日本でよくあってますけど
生きている人を馬鹿にして死んで腐る遺体になったら拝む
だからそこで我々のちょっとすごい勘違いがあることは見えるはずなんです
体の恩寵で生きていると
肉体賛嘆する生き方をしています
みんなこの体 ありがたい体で生きているんだと
だから世の中を見ると
もう肉体のためにすべて
心のために何一つもやらない
だからこれってものすごい法則違反なんです
心がすべてやっているんです
心が指令を出しているんです
指令を出して心が体を動かしているんです
なのに ほうれん草のおかげで元気になったと
ほうれん草を拝む だからそれ決めたのは心でしょうに
ほうれん草の成分を調べたのは心でしょうに
それでほうれん草をどう食えば体に入るのかと決めたのも心でしょうに
生で食べるか お湯に入れて出してなんとか絞って食べるかとかね
それで心が決めたでしょうに
それで食べても心がなかったら消化しませんよ
物質のはそんな気持ちないんです
消化させるのは心なんです
物質は物質で置いておけばそのまま
何もやりません 物質は自分で変化しているだけで
で なのに我々はものすごい法則違反で
体を拝んでいるんですね
心の無知のせいで生きることはハチャメチャ混乱する
だから指導者を馬鹿にしているんだから
司令官を最高司令官を馬鹿にしているんだから
だから人生はハチャメチャですよ
苦難に満ちた安らぎがない結果になるんです
これはまあ 仏教的にそういうことになるんです
人間が別に苦しまなくてもいいんです
悩まなくてもいいんです
落ち込まなくてもいいんです
で 心の管理がしていない
心がなんか変です ですから
心に闇があるんですよ
自分の力に気づかないので物質に依存する
これは仏教では無明 無知というんですけど
無明だから もともとアホだから心が
自分が王様なのに王であることは知らないんです
相当なアホでしょ 自覚がないんだから
だから心がまず第一の間違いを起こすんです
物質に依存するんです
それは仏教でいう執着
それで自由が奪われています
だから心に自由がなくなって
誰のせい？心のせいでしょうに
それに関連して 欲 怒り
嫉妬 恨み 憎しみ 落ち込み
傲慢などの1500種類の病のキャリアになっているんです
正しく数えれば1510なんですけどの病気を持ってキャリアと
英語単語はキャリアなんですね
日本語で何といいますかね
最近 保菌者 保菌者になっているんです
あの1510もいつでも発病するわけじゃないんです
時と条件によって 何かの病が常に活動しています
だから いつでも我々には心が病気なんです
同じ病気じゃなくて 病気が変わるんです
一つの病気を置き換えて別な病気になる
それを置き換えて別な病気になる
例えば 若い青年たちが友達と遊びに行こうとする
その遊びに行ってふざけて欲に絡んで
それは病気なんですね
それで母親が出かけるそうと言っちゃうと
母親はどこに行くのかと聞いて
もう悪い友達と遊ぶことをわかって
もう行くなよと で 怒る
そうするとお母さんに対して怒っちゃう
怒っちゃうんだよ 怒って喧嘩して
それでも出て行く だからお母さんっている時は怒りと病気にかかっちゃって
お母さんのとこで出て行って
友達の中に入っちゃうと欲の病気にかかっちゃうんです
だから常に何かしらの病気があるんです
心に病がない瞬間はありません
それはお釈迦様の言葉なんですよ
体は時々 100年経っても何の病気もない肉体があるんだけどね
だって物質ですからね
しかし心は病気でない瞬間はありませんよと
はい 一つのチャプターが終わりまして
次のセクションに行きます
トワースプロデュースパワーという
まあちょっとかっこつけるために英語で書いたんです
で 思考妄想は力を発揮する
で 今ちょっとくだらない本を読んでいますけど
そちらにある文章があって
もう中で読んでいて あのトーツアー things という
thoughts というのは思考ですね
ア things ものであると
いわゆる思考とはものであると
それはもう西洋の 的なアメリカ人の言葉だからね
どうでもいいんだけど
私はもっと丁寧に まあトールプロデュースパワー
思考は力を造ります ジェネレーターなんです
力の思考は ものと性格を変える
ただの思考 ただの妄想と済みますでは済みません
とではなくて まあただの妄想でしょと言って軽く思ってるでしょ
冗談です 危ないんです
ただの妄想でも思考だからね
エネルギーを作っているんです
だからアメリカ的に言えば
これものなんです 危ない
何かものを作っちゃったんです
それは正しい言葉ではないんだけど
あの まあ仏教でも思考はものをつくるって言ってますよ
物質を作る アビダンマではものを作るということは
この地水火風を作っているんですね
だから我々の思考によって結構物質が新たに宇宙に入るんです
加えるんです で これまあつまらない例で言えばね
例えばあのアパートを借りて引っ越しする
アパートは何もない カラカラでガラガラでしょ
引っ越しして 1年経つと
例えば引っ越しするときはちょうどカバン 2つで行ったかも 1
年経ってまた引っ越しする羽目になっちゃうと
トラック軽トラック 1台は必要になるんですね
これ物が増えたのは誰のせい？思考のせいなんです
それってわかりやすいんだけど
そうじゃなくて 思考が本当に地水火風を作るんです
わずかな思考 妄想さえ力に力を創ります
だからとても危険か どうでもいいんだけど
無責任ではなくて 重くこれ理解しなくちゃいけないです
考えるでエネルギーが生まれているんです
たったわずかな考えでも
エネルギーになっているんです
エネルギーは結果出します
止まりません その力は本人の心の流れに影響を与えます
だから 私の思考 妄想で私の心の流れが変わっちゃうんですね
そうすると 私の生き方も変わっていて
体も変わっていて 周りも変わっていっちゃいますよ
これは毎日起きていることなんですね
自分の体にも周りにも影響を与えます
例えば 強盗したいという人が思う
そうすると それに適して自分の体を変える
環境を変える バレないようにいろんなからくりをする
いろんなことを だから
子供の思考パターンで家が変わってしまいます
家に住んでいる他の人々の生活習慣も変わっていくんです
家の他の人々の思考パターンでまた家が変わっちゃうんです
他の人々の生き方も変わっちゃうんですね
だから思考というのはそういうものなんです
家族3人で住んでるならば
子供の思考で 親2人の思考も
犬猫いるならば そちらの生き方も影響を受けて変わる
家の中も変わっちゃうんで
子供の思考パターンで
そうすると父親の思考パターンで家の中が変わるし
犬猫の生活習慣も変わるし
もうあの二人の生き方も変わっちゃうんです
お母さんの思考パターンでまた同じ結果になる
それで最終的な結果は
その3人との思考パターンで起きてるんです
それで飼っている犬も犬の性格を持っていると
また家の中の雰囲気変わっちゃいます
物事は変わります 猫も猫で自分なりに特別な思考パターン
習慣を持っているならば
それにまた家が合わせなくちゃいけないんです
家だけではなくて 住んでいる人々も
それってわかるでしょ
それで毎日経験していることでしょう
思考はただで済みませんと
思考はすごい影響を与えるんだと
自分にも周りにも その結果で結果私たちは受け取っているんです
それから結果悪い時は結果に悪口を
なんで私はこんな不幸なのかとかね
なんで私はやることは何でも失敗するのかとか
誰かのせいだと思っているんです
日々気づかないのですが
時間が経つとどれほど思考妄想が影響を与えたと理解できます
例えば暗い思考でいる
別にまあ 1 日暗い思考に浸っていただけで大丈夫と思っているでしょう
じゃあ 2 日間  3 日間くらい思考に浸ってみてください
どうなるのかと 家が変わっている
自分の体が変わっている
暗い思考に合わせて体が動かない硬いものになっている
体の柔軟性がなくなっている
循環がすごく悪くなっている
そうすると仕方がなく
その結果見て あー嫌だ
この結果でさらに不幸な暗い思考をする
ああ 体調も悪いし 腰も痛いし
もう体も硬いし もう嫌だ
これはまた同じ暗い思考をする
で ひどい病気になって倒れたりもする
だから時間経ったらわかるんだけど
その時はもうお祭りですね
終わってるんです もう自分の行為の結果はもう受けるしかないんです
ですから 思考妄想の知識が必要なんです
制御しない思考妄想の流れがとても危険です
なぜならば これ自然に任せてはいけない
心は初めからも勘違いしているんです
初めからも自分が王様なのに王であることは知らない
自分が指導者なのに指導者であるとわからない
物質が神様やと思っているんです
西洋文化というのは明らかにそういう文化でしょ
心優先であるとわかったら
例えばある国で心が優先であるとわかったら
その国にはこういう試験破壊するくだらないこのからくりいらなくなっちゃうんです
ただ自然の中で美しく穏やかにいられます
病気にもかからない だから病院はいらなくなっちゃう
誰とも喧嘩しない そうすると法律
システム 警察もいらなくなる
心 心が優先であると思ったら
他の人間管理する必要もない
ですから政府もいらない
そこで唯一平和のみという楽天が現れるんです
楽園 楽園が現れるんです
でもやらないでしょ 誰も
いくら言ってもこの根本的な無知
錯覚 誤解を直さないと
自分が指導者であることに気づかないと
何も始まりません で なんで心の流れが良くないかというと
なぜなら心が煩悩で病んでいるからです
闇の心の闇思考 闇妄想は幸福
安らぎ 安穏 平和 調和の結果はを出しません
だって人は病気になっちゃうともう怒るだけでしょうに
そこで平和がないでしょうに
心が病気で 病気の思考
病気の妄想 いわゆる思考が病気です
妄想も病気ですから 結果も苦しい結果になるんです
難しいのは 覚悟の上ででもブッダに説かれた善思考を行わなくてはならないのです
だから我々の心は根本的に勘違いしているんだから
それで思考するんですよ
変えるのは難しいんです
ですから 難しいとこを覚悟して善思考に入れ替えなくちゃいけないんです
人間知らない 何が善思考であるかと
人間が正しいと思って考えるものは一つも正しくないんです
すべて欲のためなんです
例えば お客さんにすごく丁寧で優しく対応するべきでしょうと
なぜか 儲かるんだからです
だから思考は汚れてるんです
仏教は儲かるかないか
この汚い考えを捨てて
優しい心でいてみなさいと
どこでもあなたにとっては平和な世界だよと
だからこの善思考っぽいものは俗世間にもあります
あるんだけど やっぱりあれ
病んだ心が作った思考なんです
他の道はありません 仕方がないんです
皆様にギャーギャー言う権利すらないんです
だって何か理論立てたっても
病んだ病んだ思考でしょ
病んでる理論でしょ もともとも自由が失っているでしょ
だから悟りに悟りに達した
煩悩をなくしたブッダが智慧を開発して
智慧でこういう風にやりなさいと道を教えているのでも仕方がないんです
その道を歩むしかないんです
存在とはファンクションです
機能です はい 次 生きるって何ですか？と
生きている 我々に命があるという言葉をよく使っているでしょう
それはまとめて存在ですね
存在とは何なのかと 存在とは実体ではなく
常に変化する機能です
だからアメリカ人が言ったのは thing ではない
モノではないんです ただの機能です
生きるということは あの物質モノで見えるんだけど
モノじゃないんです マイクロフォンはモノで見えるんだけど
触ったらモノとして触れますけど
モノではないんです ある機能です
物質も機能です 心も機能です
物質は機能であるということはね
物理学を大学で学んだら教えてくれると思います
エネルギーだよと 最終的にはモノではないんだよと
例えば酸素というものはモノでしょうかと
酸素のあれ エレクトロンをね
取り出しちゃうと酸素でなくなっちゃうんです
飛び飛び飛ばしていくんです
飛ばしていっちゃったら酸素も酸素ではないんです
心の働きは認識する 思考妄想することです
ですから 心ってものではないんです
マイクロフォンすらものではないのに
このテーブル 机も物ではないんです
皆様が座っている椅子も物ではないんです
すべて機能です 機能だから変化する
機能って仕事してるでしょ？だから変化する
心は当たり前 純粋機能です
だから科学者はなかなか発見しないんです
心は 科学的に発見不可能になっています
科学者には機能がものに化けたら発見できます
そうすると計量を図ってみることも
もう何もできます データを取ることもできます
科学はやっぱり機能がものに化けた時
ものがあるという前提で研究するんです
そこでものがあるという前提で研究していたところで
最終的には原子も素粒子でできているんだと
核も素粒子でできているんだと
それはものじゃないんだと
とわかってはいるんですけど
それだけで終わっちゃうんです
そこで心の機能とは？働きとは
認識すること 思考すること
妄想することですね 仕事 3つあります
その行為は次の行為に影響を与えます
心だ 心の行為も次の行為に影響を与えますよ
だから今の今の瞬間に私の心が働いている
その働きで次の心の働きが決める
それで次の心の働きが決まってしまいます
生命の行為は心の行為を生み出します
そこで我々生きている人々は喋る
見る 音を聞く ご飯を食べる
仕事をするといろんなことをやっているでしょ
呼吸している 寝る あれやこれやとやっていますね
洗濯をする 服を着る これすべて誰がやっていますか？心がやっているんです
ます思考が生まれるんです
ああ ご飯食べなくてはとかね
ご飯食べなくてはと思考が生まれてたら
それで体を動かしちゃうんです
心が指令するんです 動きなさいと
冷蔵庫を開けなさいと
なんかなんか食べ物たくさんあるんだけど
どちらにしようかと心が決める
はい こちらにする はい
それ取って じゃあもうレンジを開けて
じゃあ入れて まあ 3 3 分チンしようとかね
心が決める 心が決めたら体がやってくれる
それで私はバカだから
すべて体がやってくれると
電子レンジのおかげで温かくなってくれたと
なんてバカかと 次の行為に影響を与える
ポテンシャルがあるから
仏教で業というんです
これを仏教でいう業なんですね
例えば何か思考したらポテンシャルがになって次の行為に影響を与える
例えばお腹が空いたと思ったでしょ
食べなくてはという気持ちになった
そこでまた心が甘いものを食べて食べたいと思っちゃう
そうするとご飯の代わりに甘いものに手がいっちゃうんです
で ケーキ食べたいと思っている人がサラダの皿を持ちませんね
こちらケーキもあって
またサラダにサラダも皿にある
別な皿にケーキ食べたいと言ったら
何のことなく手がケーキの皿に行きます
だから毎日当たり前の話でしょ
こんなの不思議 難しくないでしょ
ただちょっと観察してください
例えば食べる時は 食べ物は 4つぐらい並べている
餃子もある おにぎりもある
他何でしたっけ？まあ
ソーセージもある マッシュポテトもある
そこで自分の手が 4つもこうやって取る
取りませんね そこで何かに手が行くでしょ
その時ちょっとチェックしてください
自分の心が ソーセージ食べたいと決めたんだと
あるいは 4つも食べたいと決めても
順番決めたんですね 心が
まずソーセージ食べなさいと
だから手がソーセージに行くんです
次の人の心が順番でいい
ポテトを食べてくださいと食べましょうと決めたら
ポテトに手が行くんですよ
こんなのはチェックしてください
すごいシンプルでしょ
弁当の中に箸が行くときは
どちらに行くのかでチェックしてください
弁当にいろんな種類あるでしょうに
そこで箸が行ったところで
すぐ心をチェックしてください
心がそこ食べなさいと言っているんです
決して別なところには行かないんです
だから弁当を食べてるとか
弁当一部食べて またお茶をちょっと飲んで
また口を拭いたり いろんなことをやっているでしょうに
そうすると心がかなり回転しているんですね
まず思考する 次に行為をする
だから行為をするためにはエネルギーが必要でしょう
そのポテンシャルのエネルギーに仏教で業というんです
だから あまりにも頭が悪すぎちゃって
業っていうのは宗教的な神秘的な言葉だと
ではないんですよ 皆様
学んでいる科学よりも明確な確固たる科学なんです
空になる思考はありません
実らない思考はないんです
ポテンシャルにならない思考はないんです
業にならない思考はないんです
だから こんな冗談でふざけて生きることっていうのはどうでしょうかと
五感で情報を感じる認識機能は業になります
それでもちょっと exception あります
exception って何だったっけ？例外
全ての思考は結果出します
が ちょっとした例外があるんです
例外はこの五感で認識するとき
目が開けてると見えるでしょうに
見たい見たいと気持ちなくても見える
耳が空いてるんだから閉じることできませんだから聞きたい聞きたいでなくても
空気に音があれば聞こえる
しかし それから流れる思考は結果出します
それから結果出します
空気に音があったら聞こえるんですよ
聞こえてから結果出す思考を流れるんです
聞こえた瞬間は何のこともないんです
結果出しません 理性のある人は無責任で思考妄想にふけることはしないんです
理性ある人が気をつけて生きているんです
ふざけて無責任で気楽では生き生きません
ちょっと間違ってます
この文章は  あなたが  うん
これは覚えるフレーズですね
それが打ち間違えたんだから
まあこれは英語で考えて日本語にしちゃったんだから
ちょっと苦労したんですね What
you think what you はなんで英語で言えば簡単ですね
あなたがどのように考えるのかによって
あなたの人生はそのように流れます
すごいことですよ 皆様
色んな持ってるかも 私も幸せになりたいと思ってるんだけどね
幸せになれてない なってはないんだという話でしょ
いろいろ希望があるんだけど
なかなかうまくいかないんだと
それが仏教のせいじゃないんです
あなたの心が病んでるせいなんです
例えば 金持ちになりたいと思うでしょ
その時 本当の心がなるわけないでしょうにと
我は私はもう不幸であることは決まってるでしょうにという本当の思考
だから本当の思考は結果出しているんです
詐欺思考じゃないんです
詐欺思考で苦しむだけ
金持ちになりたいなと思っていろいろくだらないことをやりますよ
それで苦しむんだけど
結果として貧乏は貧乏で終わっちゃうんです
だからこの詐欺思考上に流してるんですよ
詐欺思考で人を困らせるだけ
結果は本思考でちゃんと結果が出てくる
だからこの本思考によって人生が変わるんです
あ What you what you get is what you think
はい それで一つのセクション終わりました
3番目に入ります はい
あの これはチャプターごとに分けて喋りますから
なんか本読んでるような感じになりますけどね
面白くないね その場合は
講義というよりは 思考のネットワーク
現代的にちょこちょこっと持ってきます
心は他の心とつないで力を発揮します
この心の一つ 法則なんですね
他の心とつないで つないだならば
より力になります 思考と行為
日常生活程度のことは自分の思考で思考
行う  喉が渇いたら水を飲むぐらい
トイレに行くぐらい 眠くなったら寝るとか
そんな程度の日常生活は自分自身で考えてやることはできます
本当に大したことではないんです
他人の力が入ると実効力が強くなります
しかし 他人の力が入ってくる
他人の心が入ってくると
心が繋いだということは力が入ったということなんです
思考は力 例を出します
子供は自分でやるべきことは知ってはいるが
実行させるためには母親の指令
言葉を待っているんです
ただ 子供が明日学校の宿題やらなくちゃ
宿題やらなくちゃ でもゲームやりますという感じでいるんです
でも漫画を読みますとかね
だから子供の思考に力がない
だから実行に行くまで力がない
漫画を読むことには力が入って漫画を読んでいる
面白くて 漫画読んでいる場合じゃない
宿題やるんだよって言ってますよ
それで母親があんた何やってるの？宿題やりなさい
お本を捨てなさい 言っちゃうと
すぐあ はいはいと言って宿題に入ります
だから母親の宿題やることできませんよ
子供が自分の体でやらなくちゃいけない
そのエネルギーは 母親の心が繋いだところで生まれたんです
これで母親の思考の力が子供に入ったんです
入って宿題をやるようになっちゃうんです
これって毎日のことでしょ
皆様の珍しい話じゃないでしょ
決して珍しい話じゃないんです
毎日経験してるでしょ
時々私も買い物に行った方がいいなと
ちょっと誰かに言うんですよ
自分が行くつもり 動かないんですよ
買い物をしないといかないな
今日はどうしようかと
で いわゆる買い物をするべきという思考はあるんだけど
弱い思考は体を動かすぐらいエネルギーを持っていないんです
体を立たせて 財布を持って外へ出て行かせるぐらい力を持っていない
そうすると 私は隣の人に言ったら
その人はああそう じゃあ一緒に行きましょう
あの一言で あ そうね じゃあって何のことなく動く
不要であっても すごいエネルギーになっちゃうんですよ
隣にいた人の一言で だからまあ
今私はすごい年寄りですけど
私の若い頃 本当はあったんですけどね
で その時はやっぱりいつでも周りで言われるわ
言われるわ 言われるわ
言わない 言われるとやるんですね
でないと動かないんですね
順番知ってます どんな時間で何やるべきかと知っている
知ってるんだけど ずるずるずるすると自分やっていることをやっているんです
そうすると 周りのお坊さんたちが
あんた何やってるの？今ここやる時間でしょうと
言うと ああ そうですねと
そこで動くんです これって誰でも同じことでしょう
自分がやりたがっていることを他人に言ってみてください
実行する力が強くなります
だから 自分の希望とかやりたいこととかあったらあっても動かない場合は
友達に家族に言ってみて
こういう考えがあるんだけどとか
奥さんに言ってみる やっぱり奥さんが怒るでしょうね
お前はいつでももう考えてるだけでしょとか
言われると何か腹が立って
すぐ実行するんです だから
あの言葉で力が生まれたんです
はい 他人のライフはどういうことか
それなんです 他人の賛成
同意 応援 認めは自分の生き方
行為 行動に力になります
これは本物の力なんです
みんな自分がやっていることにライクを入れてくれると
すごい元気になって力になるんです
なおさら活動できるようになる
私の本でも読んでね ああ
よくいい本でよくわかりやすかった
面白かったとかね もう人生が変わりましたと言ってくれれば
なおさらいい本を書けますけど
誰も言ってくれません
これってもうどうしてもならんで法則だから
すごいわかりやすい本でしたとかね
言ってくれれば 次の本はもっとわかりやすくなるんです
言ってくれないんだからしょうがないんです
私一人の力で ちっぽけな力で終わっているんです
物質も互いに影響を与えます
無理に合成することもできます
ん？これもちょっと間違いだと思いますけど
あの ん？物質もある程度で互いに影響を与えますよ
例えば鉄だったら錆びますね
それは鉄の問題ではありません
鉄は柔らかいんです 酸素っていうのはすごい頑固
わがままなんです 酸素の元素はすごい不安定なんです
一番外にある枠がね エネルギー枠のシェルがあるんですね
外にあるエネルギーの殻がすごい不安定なんです
そこで誰かのものにつなげちゃうんです
だから鉄の電子に一つ取ってしまいます
鉄の電子を取り取っちゃうと
鉄には自由がなくなっちゃうんです
酸素とぶつけてつなげていなくちゃいけない
それは我々錆びるという酸化するんですね
そうすると鉄と錆は違うものなんですね
同じものじゃない また無理に酸素を捨てちゃう
追っ払うとまた鉄に戻ります
しかし 人間の心が入ってくると
一緒にならないものも合成させることができます
だから我々は今 合成した品物の中で生きていますね
私の目の前にあるこのマイクロフォンであろうが
ノートパソコンであろうが
すべて合成したものなんです
無理やり このほとんど今
化石燃料で作ったプラスチック製品を使っているでしょうね
プラスチック系のね 私の草履もそうでしょうし
それって自然にないんです
だから 人間が無理やり合成するんです
で そこで言いたいのは
あの合成すると力発揮します
だからこの昔はね 古典の服を着ていたんですけど
古典っていうのはもの空気でも飛んでいくすごい軽いもので
古典の板糸っていうのはすぐ破れちゃうし
それで人間がそれはつなげてつなげて糸にして
それから編んで それから生地にして
それから服にするとすごい力そう
100%の綿の服であっても
手では破れませんよ ハサミじゃないと
でも線一つ取ってみるとすごい柔らかい空気に飛んでいく
だから私たちはそれ合成して力強くしたんです
この合成機能が心にも起こるんです
心に合成機能が起こるからこそ
物質も我々は意図的に合成するんです
そこでこの他人のライフというのはそういうことなんです
私の考えに やっていることに他人が賛成すると
そこが来て合成してより強い思考になるんです
より行動力を持っているエネルギーになるんです
だから常に我々の心が他人の考えで
心で合成して合成しているんです
だから仏教は無我っていうのはあなたないんだよと
初めからも 今私がいるんだけど
講演終わったら誰かと喋っていると
その人のアイデアと合成して別人になっちゃうんです
だから我々は常に人のアイデアを受け入れて
そこで合成する この like だけではなくて
dislike でも同じなんです
合成するんです  dislike で当然弱くなるというね
まあ例えば私の装備はすごく強いんですけど
なかなか破れない強いもんですけど
まあでもこれはプラスチック合成だから
軽いんだから入ってますけどね
何かティンナーとかなんとか入れちゃうとマイナス合成になるんですね
シンナー入れちゃうと
これはものがぐにゃぐにゃになっちゃって破れる
これは物質の場合 心の場合も同じこと
例えば 子供が何かやろうと思って強い気持ちで思っている時は
母親が断然反対とやるなよと強く言っちゃうと
これは dislike でしょ
dislike ボタンを押しちゃったんですね
あまりにも押しすぎちゃって
子供の希望が やる気が壊れてしまいます
あ やばいと思ってやらないことになる
そういうことで 我々は常に
24 6時間 24時間で
24時間 何言ってるか自分でわからなくなって
心は我々は合成しているんです
他人の心と だから like だけじゃない
時々 dislike もすごく必要なんです
個人の個人は意図的に
心は常にネットワークで働きます
個人の意図的に個人は意図的に
不自然に孤立しようと無理に努力します
個性ではなく 自我という病です
そこで私たちはまた間違いを起こすんです
だって心はもともと もともと間違った線路に乗ってるでしょ
だからこの 大阪に行きたいのに
東北線の線路に乗っているんですね
大阪に行けるわけないでしょうに
だから心は最初からも自分が弱い
力がない 物質至上主義という勘違いで不幸の線路に乗っているんです
苦しみの線路に乗っているんです
だからこの線路を入れ替える
乗り換えることは仏教は教えています
ちょっと乗り換えなさいと
あなたまだまだ東京にいるんだよと
東京駅にいるんだから
どちらでも乗れるんです
そこでまた心次にやる間違いは
この自分のアイデンティティ
自分のプライバシー 私の思考の自由とか
ありもしないくだらないことを言っているんです
思考に自由がないんです
自分の自由な思考を紙に書いてみて
紙でなくてもいいんで
携帯のメモにも書いてみて
書いてから読んでみて
自由な思考かと なんでこんな嘘を言ってるんですかね
フリーダムオブシンキングとか
ありえしあり得はしないんです
仏教はすべて因果法則やと言ってるんだから
その時点で自由っていうのは成り立たないんです
これだからこうなっている
これはどうにもならんでしょ
ガソリンに火をつけたら燃える
因果法則でしょ ガソリンに火をつけたら桜の花が咲いてきたってありえないでしょ
因果法則とはもう自由がもともとないという意味でもあります
ですから 我々は私の思考
私の自由な考えとかね
私の考えを放っておきなさいよと
あなたごちゃごちゃ言う必要はないんだよと
言ってますけど あれ正しい
あれは心が病気です あれは自我という病気なんです
自我の病気はすごい怖いんです
自我の病気で我を張って
社会に迷惑をかけて 環境に迷惑をかけて
破壊行動に行くんです
不幸の方向に行くんです
ですから 皆様知ってるでしょ？皆様も自分が別や
自分が違うものやと思いたいでしょ？孤立したいでしょ
自分の思考というのは自分の思考じゃないと発見していないでしょ
私の思考 がないんです
今私が喋ってる私の思考じゃないんです
すべて私の思考パターンが
ブッダの解かれた教えによってぴったしと整理整頓されているんです
どうにもならん 別な考えを入れることは私にはできません
不可能 ですから 誰だって私の考えと勝手に思ってください
思って自我 落ちてくださいという言葉しか言わ言わざるを得ないんです
あなたの思考にふけったら
はい どうぞ地獄に行ってくださいと
すぐそばにあるんだよと
だからこういう風に宇宙法則で物事を見ると
自我って消えちゃうんです
病気が はい それからソーシャルメディア
これカタカナ調べたんだけど
出てこなかったんです
現代のネット社会は不確
不確定 何でしたっけ？不確定の他人とのね
意見をつなぐことができるようになっているんですね
だから 昔よりは今 私たちにはネット社会が現れたんだから
たくさん人と自分の意見を交換することができるようになっています
それでまた勘違いする
それってアメリカの研究者が作ったことじゃないんです
心がネットワークを作りたがっていたんです
心が他の心のアイデアを受け取って
自分で力強くなりたかったんです
だから心がネットワークシステムを作ったんです
今のネット文化もソーシャルメディア文化も
結局は心が作ったもので
心がよりたくさんデータが入った方が
自分の思考には力が入るんだよと知ったんです
権力者独占している権力は一般人の手にある程度
入ってるんです だから昔は我々は全部権力者言うこと
はいはいとかね 政治家喋ったら
ああ その通りやとかね
バカみたいに生きていたでしょうね
今はトランプさんにも悪口言う
どうするのかと 来て殺すのかと
できません もしアメリカ人にその気になったならば
トランプさんをもうもう
そう 何て言うのか このプレジデントから追い出すことはできます
そんなのはアメリカ憲法でないとか関係ないね
できますよ みんなもう書けばもう権力者の権力がなくなっちゃうんです
しかし その場合はたくさん合成しないと力が足りません
ただ 私が一人で えーと
何でしたっけ？トランプさん
早く辞任しなさいと なるなりません
まあ一人な頭イカれてるバカがいるんだと
それが 1億人の人々が言っちゃうとどうなる？頭がイカれたバカでなくなっちゃうんですね
あ やべえってことになるんです
だからこのアイデアの交換というのは本物の力なんですよ
だからトーンイズパワーなんです
本物の力なんです しかし
人類には正しい戒め 正しいしつけがないので
良い結果は少なく 悪い結果が多くなっています
問題はまた人間の心にあるんです
人間の心は古からの間違ったスタンスで活動しているんです
だから我々は今 たくさん情報のやりとりできる世界を作ったんだけど
結果から見ると悪い結果が多くて
良い結果は少ないということになっているんです
悪意の人もライクをもらえば実行に行くんです
だから悪意の人でも自分の意見を発表したら
ライクたくさん来るとやりますよ
やります やります いたって簡単
例えば誰かさんがを殺したいと一人が書く
これでみんなもうライク出して出して出して
もう 10万人も 20万人も人はやりなさい
やりなさいと もうライクばっかり増えるとどうする？その人はどうしよう仕方がなく
あの人を殺さなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんで
堂々とやっちゃいます
そういうことで この情報っていうのは
そうやってこの善悪を判断しないんですよ
あの交換に入ります えーと
心は繋がります 繋がないでいることはできません
私は気にしてないんだけど
何も気にしてないんだからね
もう全部心が繋がってます
犬の子 犬猫を飼ってみると心が繋がるんです
で 繋ぎ方 これから勉強しましょう
心に心の法則があります
だからこの心は自分の法則で繋がるんです
まず 似た者同士 よくわかっていることで
善人は善人と 悪人は悪人と繋がるんです
怒り 嫉妬 恨みの性格があると
似た性格の人と繋がる
で これわからないと思うでしょ？学校に行ってみて
大学に行ってみて クラブ活動あるでしょ？あれって似た者同士の繋がりでしょ
一人では弱いのですが
仲間がいると強くなります
バイオリンを弾きたいという性格の人と
また同じくバイオリンの弾く練習する人々とグループを作るんですよ
そうすると自分にも練習に力が入ってくる
一人ではもう全然動かないんですね
で グループ作っちゃえば
で 力発揮します 自然の流れで仲間を作ると
自分の性格は向上するのではなく
強くなるだけです あの向上と強くっていうのはちょっと違うんですよ
向上するということは
悪い性格はどんどん良い性格になることなんです
強くなるということは
今の性格がすごい頑丈になることなんです
ね だから嫉妬深い 嫉妬深い人が嫉妬の人とクラブを作るんです
そこでどうなるのかというと
すごい嫉妬強い人間になるんです
嫉妬しない人間になったわけじゃないんです
それを書いてるんです
性格は向上しない 代わりに強くなる
今は世界にあるテロリスト組織もそういうことなんです
一人ではものすごい腰抜けないです
体さえ隠してるんです
すげー臆病者です しかし
グループになっちゃうと何やるかわからない
長所も短所も強くなりますよ
どちらでも長所がある人は
長所が同じ長所の人と仲良くなるし
短所の人も同じ短所を持っている人と仲良くなるんですね
だから この仏教 お釈迦様が教えているこの心理学法則っていうのは
いたって簡単に理解できます
似た者同士 その一言でわかります
それで 病む心のつなぎについてさらに勉強しましょう
生命の心は病んでいます
問題ないんです 病む心同士でつなげます
だから 1,910種類の病気があるでしょ
それで同じ病気 人はつなぎます
心は貪瞋痴なので他人の貪瞋痴とつながります
我々は煩悩で繋がるんですよ
しかしこれ安定しないんです
なんかやばい繋がりなんです
やばい組織なんです いつ潰れるかわからない
テーラワーダ協会みたいに
もう今年もう潰れるだろうと思ったのはすごい危機感じて
で だからこの貪瞋痴で繋がるとそうなるんです
安定しない この理由を説明します
怒りの性格の A さんが同じ性格の B さんの仲間になって
第三者である C さんに対して怒りを抱きます
それで A さんも怒りっぽい B
さんも怒りっぽい そこで二人が C さんより第三人者に怒るんです
グループでもいいんで
A グループ B グループ
が グループ二つ一つになって C グループに怒る
しかし  A の怒りの対象に B も入る可能性が高い
だから仲間同士で互いに怒っちゃうんですね
だって C さんに対して怒るんだけど
あいつを殴りましょうと
言うと B さんがね まあ殴ることは後回しにして
ネットで悪口書きましょうと
それとなんでこいつは私の意見に反対しやがっちゃって
殴った方があいつを痛い目に遭うのにとか
ここで二人が互いに怒ったでしょ
そうすると仲間同士の喧嘩になります
これって分かりやすいでしょ？結構あります
同性っていうのはいつでもグループ作っちゃうでしょ
中に入ってみちゃうと
なんかすごいんですよ
お互いにいろんなことを言ったりとかね
憎しみあったりとか なんで何やってるのかと
現代社会ではいかなる分野でもこの現象が見えます
これはもう科学分野であろうか
文化系であろうか 政治家であろうか
政治家は仲間です 同じ仲間でも互いにすごいライバルなんです
自民党は自民党としてグループなんですよ
しかし お互いに権力争いで
だって自民党に入ったのは権力欲でしょ
そこでこの人の権力を取って
自分がより上になりたいということがあるんです
だから不安定なんです
社会 世界にあるどんな組織も不安定なんです
だって煩悩で繋がってるから
次に反対 なかなかないんだけど
良い心の繋がり これは仏教で説推薦している繋がりなんです
似た者同士やってはいけませんと
しかし 似た者同士 良い二人だったら
例えば慈しみの人は慈しみの人と繋がるんです
だからそれで知ってるんだから
教会の皆さんに私は毎日慈悲の実践してくださいと言っていて
よくわかりましたと言ってくれたんだけど
なんか違うような気がしますね
で 慈しみがあると同じ慈しみを実践している人とぴったし繋がるんです
そこでどうなるかというと
A さんが慈しみの人だから
A さんが B さんを  B さんが A さんを慈しむことになるんです
不安定にならないでしょ
私はあなたが幸せであります
その人もあなたは幸せでありますようにって言うんだから
お前と仲良く別れますと
気持ち悪いと言わないんです
C さんというのは他人を慈しむ時
A さんも B さんも互いに協力します
そこで A さんがあなたが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せであります
C さん言っちゃうと B さんもそうですね
じゃあ生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと
自分も本気で真面目に言うんです
だから A さんがなんか気が弱くて
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
なんか気が弱い それで B さんもったらやっぱり生きとし生ける幸せで持って力が強くなるんですよ
本気になっちゃうんです
それでこの仲違いになる原因ないんです
A さんが B さんのことをハチャメチャ慈しんでも
B さんが嫌じゃないんです
B さんが A さんのことをハチャメチャ慈しんでも嫌じゃないんです
だから本物の繋がりが安定した幸福な繋がりが生まれますが
誰もやってないんですね
この輪が拡大しても壊れることはありません
善の繋がり これも同じ似た者同士の法則です
強くなったり壊れたりする場合は
繊細で繊細の煩悩が割り込んだことになります
それでも 例えばテーラワーダの中へでももう問題起きたり
喧嘩したりはする 仏教の世界ではハチャメチャ宗派が作って
お互いライバル意識でいるんです
テーラワーダはテーラワーダとしては分解しないんだから
それでも小さな小さなグループグループあって
衣の着方違うわ 衣に選ぶ色が違うわとかね
いろいろくだらないことでお互いグループ作ってはいるんですね
何やこりゃと言って やっぱり繊細している病が割り込んでいるんです
自分が威張りたいんだと
自分こそ正しいやという病が割り込んでくると
いくら善の輪であっても揺らぐ可能性はあります
しかし 善の繋がりは壊れません
はい では個人の道を教えましょう
個人の短所も長所も理解する
自分のます皆様にこれから道を教えます
まず皆様方は自分の長所は何ですか？短所は何ですか？とまず心に聞いてみてください
性格の問題を理解してください
直す必要ないんです 私にこういう問題がある
私にこういう問題があると
自分より優れた人と無理をしてでも仲良くしてください
自然の仲間ではないんです
自分はすぐ怒ってしまう
怒ってしまうと いつでもニコニコニコニコ人に優しい明るい人と無理をしてでも友達になってください
強引にでも そうすると心が繋ぐんだから
自分の短所がオートで治るんです
これ オートで治るんですよ
これすごいことなんです
いつでもニコニコ 何にでも冗談を言ってゲラゲラ笑っている人と仲良くしちゃうと
いつでも不機嫌でいる人には不機嫌でいられなくなっちゃうんです
オートで心が治るんです
自ら自分の性格は改良します
自ら自動で 己から 己から自分の性格は改良する
できなかった善行をできる
知らなかった 真理を知るようになる
今までできなかった良いことできるようになるわ
今まで知らなかったことをもう知っているわ
素晴らしいんですよ すべて自ずから起こるんですよ
自分一人で孤立して良い人間になると
ハチャメチャ踏ん張らなくてもいいんです
まあ大体無理ですよ それはお釈迦様だけでしたからね
できたのは ブッダはすべての生命の中で唯一一人しかいない人物ですよ
他自分でやらなくちゃいけない
だからですよ ブッダのすごいというのは
正統学者というのはありえないことをやっちゃったんです
自分一人の力で完成したんです
これは不可能です 本当は
それで私たちはそんなに良い人間になること一人勝手にハチャメチャ踏ん張らなくてもいいんです
自分の悪い性格を知って
それとはない異とと無理でもして仲良くして繋がってみる
そうすると自分の心がオートで自ずから治っていくんです
心のつながりを自然に任せるものではありません
だから決して似た者同士というような前のセクションには身を任せるんじゃない
みんな世界はそうやっている
北朝鮮が嫌な人々はグループになる
北朝鮮の好きな人々は別なグループになる
こういう煩悩で繋がっちゃうんです
それが自然です しかし
自然に逆らってください
はい 仏教のネット社会
次のチャプター 善智慧解脱を目指して
仏教は別に機械金具なくても心はネットワークネット社会ですよ
で これは地球スケールじゃなくて
心のネットワークというのは無限まで広がるんです
私たちにはアクセスできないだけでね
心はもうどんな心ともつながる
つながれる 心のネットワークというのはもう無限なんです
しかし これ 仏教のネットワークではもう自由がないんです
やっぱり制限してます
善良いこと 智慧 それから解脱
いわゆる心の病をなくす
治療するネットワークなんです
皆様が作っているネットワークは
病を拡大するネットワークなんです
俗世間が作ったものだから
あれは人工的で このネットワークもすごいリミットがあるんですよ
例えば中国人にどんなものにもアクセスできませんし
いろんな国々はいろんなところでアクセス制限している
アメリカでもかなりアクセス制限はあるんです
日本はあまりアクセス制限はしていないんですけどね
ですから仏教ではこういうまず自己観察する
信仰の行為をする前に ３つの観察する
３種類の観察する  １ アッタヒタ自分に有意義
２ パラヒタ他人に有意義
３ ウベヒタ 両者に有意義であるかと
まず考えなくちゃいけないでしょ
考えてから喋る 考えてから行動する
だから思考がする 思考をする前に
これ自分に有意義 他人に有意義
両者に有意義かとチェックして
そこをコントロールして思考しなさいと
これすごい簡単にできます
こんなことって役に立つ？こんな妄想で私ね
何か私に何かなれる やってみて
すごい暗い妄想なんかしている人々は
こんな妄想して何か幸せになる？ったら
なれないでしょ そうすると自動的にやめることになっちゃうんです
でね 別な言葉もあります
なアッタッバイバダサンワッタティナパラッバイバダサンワッティナウベバイバダサンワッティという言葉もあります
これ意味は害にならないって意味なんです
この思考は他人 私の他人の両者の害にならないとチェックするんです
チェックして思考管理する
特に出家の観察に使用します
2番目は出家の観察に使用します
1番目は在家の人々は観察するんです
この意味はちょっと違いますけど
今時間ないんで 説明するために
だから俗世間はやっぱり利益目指しているんだからね
俗世間だから ですから有意義か有意義でないかとチェックします
仏教の場合は害は与えるか与えないかという言葉を変えるんです
いわゆるすごいスタンス違うんです
自分自身の生き方が完全無害でなければいけません
これは出家にしかできません
完全無害な生き方は 皆様方は
じゃあごちそう作って食べようと思ったら
これ完全無害 どれぐらい生命は不幸になりますかね
私たちはごちそう食っちゃうと
だから この無害という言葉を出家に使うんです
だから出家は托鉢で生活しなさいと言っているのはそういうわけ
ごちそうを食べようとかね
それはなくて 鉢に入れたものを食べてください
鉢に入れたものは 当然あげる人がの残ったものなんですね
もうとっくにもう作ったものでも
あえて害を与えることじゃないんです
もうすでにもう害を与えて作った食べ物だから
例えば焼き魚托鉢にもらったら
もうとっくに魚は死んじゃって殺しちゃって
肉の破片をもう焼いてまでしているんですね
それはもう自然に戻るか
誰か食べて栄養になるかだけの話なんですね
そういうことで 何でお釈迦様が論理的に出家は托鉢やと
もともと言ったのは この無害な生き方
これは在家にはできない
だから在家はアッタイタ パラヒタでいくんです
出家はアッタ ビャーバーダ パラッビャーバーダという言葉で思考を管理するんです
個人がこの宿題をするならば
清らかなネットワークが現れます
これは個人の宿題なんです
思考を放し飼いにしてはいけません
放し飼いするとすごい猛獣ですよ
だから思考を現れる前にちゃんと有意義な思考にするという宿題
そこでサンガっていうのはこの和合なんですね
サンガの和合 出家比丘比丘尼
仏教徒の在家の男性女性がサンガです
だから仏教 ブッダの弟子になるということは
いきなり大きな組織のメンバーになることなんです
出家か在家か あまり区別はしない
みんなサンガなんです
そこでサンガに決まりがあります
互いに協力する義務があります
サンガになったら 仏教徒だったらお互い協力しなくちゃいけない
日本で私はあまり感じない
時々日本でタイの人やらミャンマーの人とかね
見るといきなりなんか心つながっちゃうんです
すぐ我々はお互いに助け合って協力し合うんです
で 仏教ということで でも思ってない
あんた仏教徒だから 私も仏教だから
じゃあ協力しよう そこまでいかない
何のことなく 自然に まあ俺の子供じゃないか
私は年上だからね まあこいつは俺の子供でしょ
という感じでいるんです
だからあれ すごく気持ちのいいつながりなんですよ
和合を壊すこと 裏で仲違いの言葉を発することなどは悪行為にしているんです
やるなよと 仲間の短所があるならば
憐れみをもってブッダの頼みだという敬意を持ってアドバイスするんです
私たちの社会でね 結構言われますよ
時々年下の人々にもね
そんなことやめなさいと言われますよ
言われても腹が立ちません
なんで年下のくせにそんなこと言うのかと
なぜかと なぜ腹が立たないんですかというと
みんなこれはブッダの教えですから
教えてあげなくちゃという敬意を持って言っているんです
例えば私の心の聞き方が間違っていると
シャミでもちょっとこれもなんとかガチャガチャになってますよと言うんです
言ったら私はそうですかね
ああ よかった よかったという感じで直すだけ
微塵もあの人に対して怒らなくしも生まれれば
なぜならば 沙門の若者でもブッダの教えだからという気持ちで言っているんです
敬意を持ってアドバイスするんです
だからサンガっていうのは素晴らしい組織なんです
お互い直してあげたり
直してあげたり 直してあげたりする
人権侵害は禁止です 悪です
だからお前はねとか それは仏教では使いません
だから例えば長老たちが子供たちを出家させて
育ちますけど 怒ったりも怒鳴ったりもしますけど
決して人権侵害しないんです
だから 出家する子供たちがだいたい 1年ぐらい経つと
自分の親よりは自分の師匠の方がものすごく愛情があるんです
ものすごい切れないつながりを作るんです
産んだ母親にはもう力がないんです
あれはもう切れちゃうんです
なぜならば これはブッダの世界の新しいつながりが現れたんです
そちらには 母親は子供の人権侵害するんだからね
これは人権侵害一切ないつながりなんです
はい 次善のネットワークを作る
次に我々はネットワークを作っていきましょう
もうネットワークを作るために
この必要なパスワードとかね
もう教えました で まあどこかの
まあ基本的にね どこかのプロバイダーと契約して
プロバイダーからパスワードをもらって
それからアクセスするでしょ
もうそのセクション説明しました
次 あなたはネットワークにアクセスする
どうやってアクセスするのかというと
四方八方 東西南北 上下に住む生命に制限なく
条件つけることなく 見返りを期待することなく
慈悲喜捨を実践するんです
これは解脱ではなく これはネットワークを作ることなんです
解脱はまた別なんです
まず仏教徒であるならば
四方八方 東西南北 上下とかね
無制限に条件なく 見返りなく
慈悲喜捨を実践する 真面目にやってみてください
自分の心がどれほどつながるのかという
植物に言ってもね あんたちょっと元気がなさそうでね
元気になってよと言ったら
次の日は元気になってます
植物はすごいゆっくりだからね
1 日はかかります 完全無欠の心のネットワークを作る努力に挑戦しましょう
するのです 俗世間の流れに流され流されないように気をつけましょう
みんなやってるからやらないことです
覚えやすいんです 皆様だったらみんなやってるんだから
でしょ？だったらやらないでください
それから善友と仲良くする
それも繋ぎなんですね
真の真の善友とはブッダ如来です
そんな完璧な人はいません
だからお釈迦様は涅槃に現れて 2600立ってるかもしれませんだけど
2600でもないんだけどね
で いいんです ブッダがいつでも私の教えがあるならば
私がいるんだよと ブッダの教えを理解すると
ブッダの心の鼓動を感じますよ
あのすごい把握しきれない人格者の鼓動は感じます
仏教を勉強して理解してみてください
ですから ブッダを友達にするんです
仏教とはブッダの教えに指導にライクをします
ブッダの教えにライクしなくちゃいけない
あれつながるんです ライクということは
自分がつながったということなんです
教えを実行する勇気が湧いてきます
ブッダの教えにあ これはいい教えですね
私がのライク この言葉は素晴らしい
じゃあ私のライクとライク入れちゃうと
知らないうちに自分が実行することになっているんです
善人になる 人格者になる
智慧が現れて解脱に達するんです
だからブッダの教えにライク入れちゃうと
必ず善人になります 人格者になる
それから智慧が現れて解脱に達します
これはお釈迦様は 100%で保証しています
ブッダを友達にしたら
誰だって解脱に達しますよと
ブッダとつながることで一切の苦しみを乗り越える
ということで 今日の講演を終了しようと思ったんだけど
この私を連れて来ようと思って
あすこさんが来た時 ちょっと思い出しちゃって
もう一つチャプター入れちゃったんです
さっさと勢いで だからちょっと言葉を間違えたとこあるかもしれませんだけど
この今チャプターいいですけど
絵描くのを忘れちゃったんです
これシェアっていう単語使わなかったんだからね
シェアとは何でした？シェアの区別能力
短くポイントだけ言います
何でもシェアするんじゃなくて
区別してシェアしましょうと
シェアできるものがあります
物や財産 例えば食べ物
服 住居などなど 知識と能力
シェアできる 感情 気持ち
シェアできる 道徳的な生き方はシェアできる
情報 情報といえば 本物の偽物がありますね
それはどちらでもシェアできる
それから真理 事実 それもシェアできる
そこでシェアの基礎 シェアって仏教用語でメッセージ
てますね 布施っていうことです
シェアっていうのはそういうことなんです
例えば ネットで人の意見を自分のサイトにシェアするでしょ
だから自分が自分のサイトにアクセスする人々に布施したんです
これは功徳にならんだけど
同じ布施の行為なんです
だから現代人がシェアシェアと言うんだけど
これは仏教用語で布施という言葉ですよ
そこでシェアの基礎があるんですよ
シェアするときでも基礎を守ってほしい
慈しみに他人の幸せを願ってしまい
シェアします ネットはやってないね
仏教の人々は慈しみでシェアする
他人の幸せを願ってシェアする
善意であっても 嘘の情報を決してシェアしません
よく言うで 善意でやりましたと
善意でやっても悪いことは悪いんです
だから嘘の情報は善意であってもシェアしてはいけません
社会の平和と秩序を支えるもの
他人の理解能力を向上するもの
自我中心的な生き方を戒めるもの
社会から受けている恩恵をお返しするもの
シェアしてください ですごく早く言わなくちゃいけないんです
それから今シェアするでしょ
お布施するでしょ お布施を受ける場合は
シェアを受ける基礎 自分の生活の支えになるもの
これよくたら私の生活は楽になる
便利になる だったらそれは受けます
理解 判断能力を上げる
拡大するもの あの人と話しちゃうと
私の理解能力はより一層強くなる
ですから その人の意見を頂きますと
お布施を頂けます というふうにお布施を受ける側が自分を
だって誰だってお布施するし
受けるし 両方だからね
我々はシェアするし で
また他人のシェアを受けているし
次 人格向上に欠かせないもの受けてください
悪感情をなくし 善に至るために必要なものは勉強してシェアを受けてください
それから 煩悩をなくすために
解脱に達するために必要なもの
道徳と智慧が備わっている目上の知識
アドバイスを受けてください
そこで道徳がある 智慧のある人はいつでもお布施しています
例えば 世界で一番誰にも敵わない
指摘できない 比較できない
お布施しているのは誰ですかね？お釈迦様です
我々お釈迦様にお寺を作ったり
仏像を作ったり 仏像を作ったり
私たち頑張っているように見えるでしょ
本当は逆です お釈迦様がしたお布施には叶う
叶うわけがないんです
だから そういう長老たちやら
道徳のある方々やら 仏教の目上の人々やら
ずっとお布施しているんです
法施というんですけどね
専門用語で それを受けてください
必ずシェアするべきもの
だから生活が楽になるものを受けても
これは必ずということはないんですね
これは必ずやらなくちゃいけない
単純に真理です 真理を教えてもらってください
迷信 感情 権力者の圧力などで自由を失っている生命に真理を説くべきです
だから仏教は説いてますよ
自由になる道 神から自由になる道
サタンから自由になる道
占いから自由になる道
あらゆる迷信から自由になる道
盲信的な信仰から自由になる道
教えています だからそこを受けてください
必ず 自分が歩んできた衝動を教えるべきです
ですから 自分自身でも実践してみて
私はこういう風にやって
こういう風に楽になってるんだと仲間にお布施しなくちゃいけない
で 仲間 それ必ず受けなくちゃいけない
唯一シェアするべき 一切の生命に価値あるものとは
ブッダに説かれた真理です
他 世の中で何もない 理由があります
他の知識 物事は一時的に一時的な効果しかありません
皆様は現代ネットワークで得る情報でシェアすることで楽になるんだけど
一時的です 長持ちはしません
いくら時間 時代経っても
2500年前に説かれた真理なんですよ
今も効き目がある 人の役に立つ
今も社会を先にの真理を教えている
これからもそうなるんです
仏教はいつでも先頭にいるんです
だから人に教えるべきもの
人が学ぶべきもの 教えるべきものは布施
学ぶことはお布施をいただく場合は真理唯一なものになるんです
はい これでやっと終わりました
ありがとうございます
はい スマナサーラ先生ありがとうございます
えーと ちょっと時間が押してしまったので
今日はちょっと質疑をこの時間は割愛して
これで終了したいと思います
4時半になりましたので
すみません  はい では終了しましょう
じゃあこれ一緒に唱えて終了します
はい 皆さんご一緒に ドゥッカパッターチニドゥッカ
バヤッパッターチニバヤ
スーカッパッターチニッスーカ
ホントゥサンビーティパーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい ありがとうございます
カンティーパラマンタポーティティンカーニッバーナンパラマンワダンティーブッダ